STILL MAKING RECORD PROFIT IN
THE QUARTER.
>> Bret: SUSAN LEE IN
NEW YORK.
TONIGHT, IRAN IS A BRACING FOR
WHAT FIGURES TO BE A MAJOR BLOW
TO ITS ALREADY SHAKY ECONOMY.
MONDAY THE U.S. REIMPOSE IS
TOUGH SANCTIONS THAT WERE EASED
DURING THE IRAN A NUCLEAR DEAL.
RICH EDSON TELLS US WHAT'S IN
STORE FOR NEXT WEEK FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
>> SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE
POMPEO SAYS THE ADMINISTRATION
IS TARGETING THE CORE OF IRAN'S
ECONOMY AND ESSENTIALLY EXITING
ITS PARTICIPATION IN THE IRAN
NUCLEAR DEAL.
ON MONDAY, THE U.S. WILL RESTORE
SANCTIONS AGAINST IRAN'S OIL,
AND SHIPPING SECTORS.
THE SANCTIONS WILL HIT 700
INDIVIDUALS, ENTITIES, VESSELS
AND AIRCRAFT.
>> IT IS AIMED AT DEPRIVING THE
REGIME OF THE REVENUE IT USES TO
SPREAD DEATH AND DESTRUCTION
AROUND THE WORLD.
OUR ULTIMATE AIM IS TO COMPEL
IRAN TO PERMANENTLY ABANDON ITS
WELL-DOCUMENTED ALLY ACTIVITIES
AND BEHAVE AS A NORMAL COUNTRY.
>> THESE SANCTIONS WILL PENALIZE
THOSE IMPORTING IRAN'S OIL
EXCEPT EIGHT AS YET NAMED
COUNTRIES.
OFFICIALS SAY THEY HAVE GIVEN
THESE COUNTRIES MORE TIME
BECAUSE THEY HAVE WORKED WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION REDUCE THEIR
IRANIAN OIL IMPORTS.
THEY ARE EXPECTED TO INCLUDE
JAPAN, SOUTH KOREA AND POSSIBLY
CHINA.
SENATOR MARCO RUBIO SAYS THEY
ARE CONCERNED.
"SANCTIONS GIVEN TO KEEP
PURCHASERS OF IRANIAN OIL, MOST
I ALARMINGLY CHINA GIVE IRAN A
FINANCIAL REPRIEVE AND SHOULD BE
ELIMINATED AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
ALSO MORE SHOULD BE DONE TO CUT
THEM FROM THE FINANCE SYSTEM IN
AN ENTITY CALLED SWIFT WHICH
HELPS ENABLES INTERNATIONAL
TRANSACTIONS.
TREASURY SECRETARY STEVEN
MNUCHIN SAYS SWIFT WILL CUT OFF
ALL SANCTIONED DOCS AS SOON IS
TECHNICALLY POSSIBLE.
GERMANY AND FRANCE ARE STILL
COMMITTED TO THE IRAN NUCLEAR
DEAL AND THEY SAY THE NUCLEAR
AGREEMENT "PROVIDES FOR THE
LIFTING OF INTERNATIONAL
SANCTIONS IN ORDER TO HAVE A
POSITIVE IMPACT ON TRADE AND
ECONOMIC SANCTIONS WITH IRAN BUT
MOST AND PARTLY ON THE LIVES OF
IRANIAN PEOPLE.
THEY SAY THEY ARE COMMITTED TO